[Applaus]
wir haben einen neuen handy alarm in
diesem moment paul ronzheimer es bei uns
hier im studio mit einem handy alarm
insofern haben wir tatsächlich einen
neuen handy alarm
bei paul ronzheimer philipp und das
kommt in der politik ja nicht gut an das
sorgt für richtig aufregung ja nicht bei
allen also der handy alarm paul
ronzheimer
paul ronzheimer das handy kann man auch
wirklich sagen ist mittlerweile kult
spätestens seit gestern paul ronzheimer
bild vize wird hervorragend versorgt von
seinen informanten aus sämtlichen
parteien weiß bei bild live immer was
jetzt in diesem moment hinter
verschlossenen türen gesagt wird ein
unglaublich wertvoller dienst an der
demokratie
für die menschen die wissen wollen was
besprochen wird aber eine politikerin
scheint sich daran sehr zu stören und
zwar schleswig holsteins
bildungsministerin karin prien die hat
sich nämlich dazu eingelassen hat sich
über den handy alarm
beschwert hat gesagt das sei der
traurige chiffre für die totengräber
jedweder vertrauensvollen zusammenarbeit
es sei ein anschlag auf unsere
demokratie ein anschlag auf unsere
demokratie pauls handy ich bin wirklich
fassungslos finde ich das lese wollen
diese politiker wirklich das alles
weiterhin hinter verschlossenen türen
besprochen wird damit hatte die union ja
gerade wirklich viel erfolg alle
hinterzimmer deals die man beschlossen
hat um armin laschet zum
kanzlerkandidaten zu machen haben der
union ein historisch schlechtes
wahlergebnis
beschert so schlecht wenn die union noch
nie vielleicht würde der union ein
bisschen mehr transparenz ja helfen und
anschlag auf die demokratie wenn die
bürger wissen was in einer
fraktionssitzung besprochen wird das ist
ja das ist doch kein geheimnis gremium
das sind auch abgeordnete die wir
gewählt haben die sind seit zwei tagen
neu im bundestag dabei weil sie unsere
stimme bekommen haben oder zumindest die
stimme von vela von deutlich weniger
wähler als letztes mal und wenn die
darüber sprechen wie es mit der partei
weitergeht fürs mit dem land weitergeht
wir uns regieren soll dann sollen wir
nicht darüber berichten dürfen wenn die
zwei stunden lang diskutieren und mit
allem abrechnen soll kein bürger davon
erfahren das gefährdet die demokratie
das ist wirklich ich bin sprachlos ich
finde auch das wort anschlag in dem
zusammenhang so unfassbar seltsam
gewählt also man kann es ja durchaus
thematisieren und sagen ach der ist es
jetzt natürlich nicht so recht ist die
sachen die wir besprechen da draußen
stoßen aber vom wort anschlag auf die
demokratie zu sprechen das ist ja
wirklich ein ganz anderes level also
wirklich wenn man die demokratie stärken
will als union gerade könnte man
vielleicht erst mal ganz offen
anerkennen wer die wahl gewonnen hat und
armin laschet der kanzlerkandidat und
cdu-chef hat gestern erklärt es gebe
keinen haupt wahlsieger wie bitte was
ist mein haupt wahlsieger was ist das
denn für ein neues wortes plötzlich in
die debatte kommt
[Musik]